[Music]
all right guys
bang bang got fred here thank you so
much for doing this thank you
great to be here absolutely let's just
get started with marathon and kind of
your background so
uh marathon is one of the largest
bitcoin miners in north america
what did you do before you were on the
board and then became the ceo
so 25 plus years running technology
companies across a variety of sectors
fintech was a big one a matter of fact
my first
programming job was at a bank um so grew
up really understanding the friction in
the financial markets
um was had the good fortune of taking
some companies public doing a lot of m
a and then switched to the dark side
became a private equity
managing partner and did leverage
buyouts of tech companies
and then started advising really large
funds and tech companies
uh i had known the ceo marathon
merrick um former ceo now executive
chairman
for many years socially our kids grew up
together
and um you know i joined the board in
2018 really to
help him with kind of this transition to
bitcoin mining and blockchain
i've always been fascinated by
blockchain i think it's a great um
leveler if you look at kind of how the
internet developed
and brought kind of the democratization
of information
i think people exposing data on the
blockchain is going to change how
businesses operate you can imagine
companies like salesforce who
effectively hold your crm data hostage
if all that data were on the blockchain
not only could you use
salesforce to access it and gain benefit
from it but you could use other
applications
so i think there's just a we're so early
in this blockchain development
bitcoin cryptocurrencies are just one
part of it
i'm a big believer in the bitcoin
blockchain being a foundation for
financial institutions
very secure fully decentralized network
you know you can say other things about
ethereum i think it has some great
benefits
but it still is less decentralized than
the bitcoin blockchain and there's just
so much you can do so i was very excited
to have the opportunity to step into
more of an operating role
at marathon and i think now is the time
where you'll see the miners become more
professional companies
you know we're real enterprises uh if
you just look at the build-out plans
most of us have you know we'll be
billion-dollar revenue companies
within the next year and a half to two
years and those become big companies and
they need to be run
in a proper way with good governance
give us an overview of marathon in terms
of just
staff revenue uh kind of footprint
globally or in north america just kind
of when somebody says to you hey you
know tell me more about kind of progress
of marathon how do you describe
the progress sure so progress to date we
just published an update
um at the beginning of the month and so
we're at the point where we've rolled
out close to uh about 20 000 miners at
this point of the 103
000 we're rolling out over the course of
this year uh
into q1 of next year uh so revenues are
beginning to ramp
um and uh we went in in january bought
about 150 million dollars of bitcoin to
put on our balance sheet
uh you know we're very well capitalized
company we have no debt uh
close to a little over 400 million
dollars of liquid assets today
and we're very focused on just building
out our production um
so we'll be at about uh little over 10
extra hash
of hash rate and come q1 of next year
we're a little over
just hitting two right now so i think
you know the growth rate's happening
nicely we're seeing
great production of bitcoin in our pool
uh which has been great
and we're not kind of cross this
threshold where we're producing over 10
bitcoin a day
which is great and uh marching forward
so we're super excited about our
progress
and uh geographically everything's in
north america one facility multiple
facilities
multiple facilities so we have uh
current facility we're building out
mostly from
is in hardin montana and that'll have
about 100 megawatts
a little over 30 000 miners and then uh
we recently announced uh the new
facility in texas which will be
about 70 000 miners uh predominantly
mostly carbon neutral
renewable energy got it um let's just
jump into there's basically three main
topics i think that everyone's talking
about marathon in
uh i always caveat these conversations
with the following
uh one most people immediately jump to
conclusions right before hearing
uh uh kind of the other side of the
story uh
two is that um when there's controversy
people always think that it's negative
impact on a business so
i look at a robin hood right everyone
was like you know drop robin hood and
everyone's yelling scream about gamestop
and then the halting of trading and
stocks
user acquisition for them went up more
than ever right so like
there's this like streisand effect that
occurs uh and then three
is um there can be a separation between
the uh kind of philosophy and the actual
application right and so i think it's
most important just like hey here's
three questions like what what is the
answers
uh so let's start with esg bitcoin right
um there's some people
who believe uh every bitcoin is a
bitcoin it doesn't matter where it's
mined how it's mined a bitcoin's bitcoin
and they're completely fungible
uh there is this kind of new
conversation around
uh separating or creating premium for uh
maybe a country that it's mined in or a
specific energy mix that it's used to
mine the bitcoin
kind of what's happened so far for you
guys from
uh this perspective and then like where
are you guys going or how do you think
about this moving forward sure great
question so
um we listen to two audiences the
bitcoin community and the institutional
investor community being a public
company the institutional investors when
asked
you know do you want a bitcoin that is
green
they say yes do you want a bitcoin that
is ofac compliant
and they say yes so based on that we
developed plans to try and develop
virgin coins that would be
environmentally sustained
with mind using environmental methods
and that would be ofac compliant
what we quickly learned however was that
the financial institutions weren't
willing to pay extra for that bitcoin
so it's kind of like saying all bitcoin
really are the same
but you know we'd like to be able to say
this is the financial institutions
that the bitcoin we buy are sustainably
mined and that they're
you know fully fat compliant but if
they're not willing to pay for that
there's no reason to do it and so we
then reversed our stance
um and quite publicly on memorial day
weekend you know i put out a video
saying you know we're
going back to the vanilla node uh we're
going to develop
and uh mine bitcoin just like everybody
else the exact same bitcoin no different
and uh yes we hold all our bitcoin on
our balance sheet
and you know we're somebody to come
along and say i'll pay you extra for
bitcoin that hasn't been
put in any other wallets you know i
don't think that's going to happen
anytime soon
but um you know that could happen down
in the future but i think really
the community believes in the
fungibility of bitcoin all bitcoin are
the same
um i'm a believer in that as well i
think that the
you know the financial institutions from
a regulatory perspective need to answer
to their
investors and to the regulators and i
think that's all going to sort itself
out i think the
miners are going to become more
transparent about esg we're going to
become more transparent about what are
our commitments
you know we've already made a commitment
that uh you know our
next deployment of 70 000 miners will be
fully carbon neutral and we'll take
the existing fleet that we have make
that carbon neutral over the course of
next year
so we'll be 100 carbon neutral and you
know we'll be
tracked and held accountable to that by
the public markets
over the course of the next year um and
then i think it's really going to be a
question of
how the market develops with what sort
of financial instruments people develop
um
you know a fund for example could say
i'm only going to buy
sustainably mined bitcoin and put it in
my fund and then they could sell shares
of that fund to institutional investors
that's a way to kind of get at the
differentiation on behalf of financial
institutions without the miners having
to do anything other than we're just
going to keep carrying on mining our
bitcoin just like everybody else
so it's fascinating to me that the
financial institutions did this right
and i think this is why the bitcoin
community kind of revolts so heavily
against this right
it's almost this belief that like the
esg conversation is just pure virtue
signaling right
so if you're demanding esg bitcoin
which frankly isn't a thing right it's
it's almost saying hey i have a bitcoin
and like where did it come from where
was it sourced from right
to some degree uh but it's acknowledging
that all the bitcoin is the same it's
just the
the production process is different um
but i'm not willing to pay more for it
means that actually they don't put more
value on it it's pure virtue signal yeah
right
and then i think the second piece is
when you get to like the ofac compliance
stuff right uh the bitcoin community
believes well the whole point of bitcoin
is you don't censor
any transactions uh the financial system
is built on literally censoring
transactions uh and actually they
weaponize the dollar and you know
all that stuff but they're not willing
to pay more for that either right and so
again it
it's kind of all virtue signal it's all
conversation it's all uh i want you to
think i'm a good person
but when it comes down to it we actually
see no difference in value between any
of this stuff and so
do you think that uh the conversation
goes away
or do you think that actually the
financial institutions
like kind of make uh financial products
or like like how does this play out in
terms of
we've been able to decipher like don't
listen to what they say watch what they
do with their money
uh but does that necessarily mean that
they won't go after this
or do you think that this is only going
to get louder it's going to become more
of kind of a mainstream conversation i
think part of it is very much
virtue signaling by the institutions
because they're
activist investors are holding them to
the to that mandate
um so i think it's not going to blow
over just the conversation will continue
to be there
um miners really have an incentive of
becoming more
environmentally sustainable it's the
right thing to do not just for the
planet but for the industry
and what's great about mining in north
america is that
we have a very good grid system
generally speaking
where you can really purchase
electricity based on a blend of power
sources
and so you have that ability to be you
know predominantly
renewable you can use carbon offsets for
certain things you can use wrecks there
are lots of way to kind of mitigate
the impact you're having on the climate
from that perspective in the environment
however you know bitcoin miners
and the industry plays a key role for
power because we enable
a renewable wind farm or solar farm to
get into business
and provide base load for us and then
build out their just power distribution
network
you know the biggest problem in power
today is not that there isn't enough of
it that's green
it's it can't get to the right places
and that's a grid and distribution issue
and you know 200 gigawatts of power is
lost a year in this country just by heat
and distribution lines
and you know you could mine a lot of
bitcoin if you just
put that base load on a facility where
they're doing solar or
or wind and until battery storage
technology gets there i think you're
going to find
bitcoin miners are the key drivers of
investment in renewable energy
i've continued to say this and literally
i've had everyone from the
climate change folks come after me to
the mainstream media folks from et
cetera
bitcoin is probably the greatest
incentive for renewable energy r d
at this point absolutely right it's just
the financial
incentive to get the cheapest power
is literally as you stated you know you
guys are minding 10 bitcoin a day
that's you know almost a quarter or half
a million bucks a day
of uh revenue for just you
right not the whole industry and so you
just kind of keep going through and i
think today
you know 35 40 million dollars a day in
mining rewards around the world and
that's only going to continue to
appreciate like
there's nothing else that has that kind
of pure free market capitalistic
perspective yeah absolutely i mean the
there's some great analogies around
bitcoin being a store for energy right
when you think about it
so we produce bitcoin it's a store of
value you can take that store of value
and go buy energy somewhere else if you
want you can go buy
whatever it is you want with it so it's
a great store it's a great conversion
of value into dollars and when you
compare bitcoin to other industries
actually and you look at the energy
inputs
and the cost inputs uh carbon inputs
even
for what they get out the other end of
economic value creation the bitcoin
mining industry is
by far one of the most profitable and
efficient
at converting energy into profits
so i think it's going to continue to be
a key part of
the electrical power grid question going
forward
and i think it's going to grow in
importance but the other thing that's
happening in the industry is
we're also seeing a huge push for
hardware to get more energy efficient
so now you're starting to see the joules
or the watts per kilo per terra hash
come down and it's going to continue to
shrink which means we use
less electricity for every terra hash
that we produce so i think you're going
to find that the power consumption of
the bitcoin mining industry is actually
going to level off
and eventually start declining as the
efficiencies kick in
yeah and the other piece and you know
i've written about it i'm sure you guys
have
plenty of people at this point it's just
like the legacy financial system has a
very
linear relationship between uh serving
more users more transactions and the
energy consumption
so if i want more users then i need more
energy or more transactions i need more
energy
bitcoin not necessarily right in terms
of just the ability to stuff
tons of economic value into a single
block uh and increase the economic value
but not necessarily increase that energy
consumption and so
uh a lot of the analysis that's done in
terms of you know bitcoin is going to
do whatever in the future it's just
built off a premise that they just don't
understand that one simple fact
talk a little bit about geographic
distribution in the mining industry
right you guys are all focused uh within
north america
um there's tons of hash rate elsewhere
in the world
uh is there a belief in your mind that
it will stay
you know pretty decentralized do you
think more and more of it will kind of
coalesce into the united states how do
you just think about where we are today
and how that evolves over time yeah i
think the
there's obviously a shift going on in
china where inner mongolia is shutting
down
mining i think the jury's still out as
to how much mining will actually leave
china
certain percentage will we're already
seeing that um
but as the hash rate in china starts
dropping below 50
of the global hash rate in north america
grows i think you're going to find that
you'll have kind of a 30 40 percent in
asia 30 40
in north america and then the balance in
europe and other rows so to say
um there's some great opportunities for
bitcoin mining in the middle east for
example
you know imagine the solar power
capability so
you know bitcoin can be mined anywhere
you can get renewable energy you don't
need infrastructure
that's the beauty of the industry and so
i think you're going to see a pretty
good decentralization
going forward it feels like uh
in some crazy way the way that the
bitcoin system is built
ends up with a globally distributed and
decentralized
system uh and
the free market does work in this sense
right like
we live in a world where every market is
manipulated and we
argue all day long over should be more
or less manipulated whatever but this is
kind of the last free market
and it's working absolutely you know
it's kind of like
um economics is a bit like water running
downhill
it'll always find its way downhill right
and the bitcoin market
you know when you think about anytime
friction is introduced into the market
it moves around it somehow and so i
think you know there's always going to
be the search for the cheapest power
there's always going to be the search
for highest efficiency
and the market's just going to continue
to develop and get better and better
more mature
and people are going to get just more
used to dealing with these very
decentralized businesses that are
created
on the blockchain so i'm super excited
about you know the future i think it's
the equivalent of kind of 1997 in the
internet
is where we are today in bitcoin let's
talk about taproot i know that
uh there were some of this was related
to kind of the ofac compliance and all
that so maybe just talk a little bit
about
your understanding of what taproot is
and then uh kind of the decision-making
process that goes into
uh signaling adoption or not adoption
sure marathon um so
taproot enables a couple of things one
it's an underlying
change that will enable the creation of
smart contracts
on uh the bitcoin blockchain this is a
really important thing i think
it's undersold because um
one of the key developments on the
ethereum platform is smart contracts it
lets you do these d5 businesses that
lets you do
really take bitcoin and the blockchain
to the next level
so between what people like stacks are
doing and other companies
taproot is really going to enable the
ability to do
the smart contract and the ability to
have a contract that is gradually
exposed as it's executed which i think
is a key part of that
it also allows for multi-sig uh
functions which is going to be critical
going forward
um why it took us longer to signal
we had to migrate all our systems back
to the vanilla core
and then we had to slowly bring all
those systems up and
start signaling for tap roots so i
believe actually today
as we're recording this we're mostly
signaling the first blocks
today most probably um so it'll be
either today or tomorrow most probably
based on you know you have to win a
block um but uh we've fully deployed it
and now it's just a question of winning
a block
got it um what's up guys bang bang i
hope you're enjoying this conversation
but before we go any further i want to
quickly tell you about today's sponsor
blockfy blockfy's got four different
financial products for crypto investors
you can deposit crypto and earn up to
8.6 apy
in an interest bearing account you can
deposit crypto and take out a us dollar
loan against your crypto collateral
you can use their cryptocurrency
exchange and have no trading fees
or you can get a new bitcoin rewards
credit card it's a normal credit card
that when you swipe you get bitcoin back
rather than back or airline miles i'm an
investor in the business and a very
happy user
i think you will be too when you go to
blockfy.com
pomp again blockfy.com pomp go check it
out and let me know what you think
all right let's get back into this
conversation i hope you enjoy it
it feels like marathon is uh the
quintessential example
of uh a business that was started
goes after bitcoin uh in terms of the
mining uh
by every measure is a bitcoin company
right
from the philosophy behind it to the
team
to the business you're actually in the
revenue driven holding bitcoin on the
balance sheet
converting your cash into bitcoin like i
mean literally you go and check all the
boxes
and then this esg thing pops up ofac and
taproot
and it feels like almost overnight the
bitcoin community went from like that's
awesome to like
you know i mean literally [ __ ] marathon
right and like just like dump the stock
and like
absolute uh i say only bitcoin community
can do like the chaos
you know by flipping a switch what
is the thought process inside the
company when all this is happening like
how much of that
uh is like noise and sense of like hey
we have a plan we're gonna continue with
the plan versus like
no we're listening to the community and
we're trying to understand you know how
much of it is like
constructive feedback versus uh just you
know people being idiots on the internet
right
like how do you think through that so
great question um
initially we were very focused on who
are the buyers of bitcoin
institutions who do we really want to
support what do we think they want
not unlike any company that's a startup
right you know you make your assumptions
about what your clients are going to
want
um when push came to shove we realized
they weren't willing to pay as we were
talking about before
for that value and the community was
very vocal
and uh i'm a big believer that in these
decentralized networks you really have
to do what's right for the community
because they do have a loud voice
and it's important to listen to that
voice because we all need to collaborate
to make this really work in the long run
and i think you know every bitcoin has
to be as fungible as every other bitcoin
and it's just a question of really
trying to balance
running a business with the right
governance and right compliance with
doing what's right for the community and
the overall growth
of you know the crypto industry and the
network it's hard to speculate on what
you would have done
you know uh offer situations that didn't
occur but if the institutions had said
hey we are willing to pay more for this
do you think that you would have stuck
to the guns and kind of continued on
that path or do you think that the
community kind of trumps
revenue right and it's a weird question
because you get into this
like revenue is the point of a
capitalistic
you know for-profit business is
literally to get profit uh
but then there's like the community
aspect to it which isn't necessarily
revenue driving but could be beneficial
or hurt the business as well and so
what what's the trade-off there i guess
or the framework so
i think one of the key aspects most
people don't think about
um is that there isn't a infinite supply
bitcoin
right there are 900 a day and if one
miner starts doing
uh full of fat compliance for example
and filters bitcoin
how many bitcoin are they really going
to create a day and is that even enough
to feed
financial institutions it's not by any
practical means
so the economic value institutions could
provide to minors for a differentiated
bitcoin
that equation doesn't really pencil
today it's
a different story i think if um a fund
were to basically go to all the miners
and say listen we want to buy only
virgin coin
and here are the terms and conditions
and we'll pay you this much more
miners will then make the economic
decision themselves as to what they're
going to do
but i think still unlike the oil and
gold industry where you can
decide to turn on or turn off your
reserves and you know grow volume
uh that way we don't have that luxury in
the bitcoin industry
we cannot buy more hardware and then you
know what a lot of people don't realize
is there's a lot of luck
in mining bitcoin it's not just you're
going to do it
um you know you've got to be really good
at what you're doing and then
you've got to win the block so you've
got to have scale and i think if
anything what we're going to see is
kind of the market turning into there'll
be a group of you know a number of large
volume miners you'll have a bunch of
mid-tier miners
who work very closely with hosting
facilities they do kind of rev share
deals that's how they kind of capitalize
their
capex and then you'll have small miners
who are really just doing arbitrage on
buying hashrate and i think there's some
really interesting markets that are
going to develop
in this industry around essentially
doing derivatives based on hashrate
so that you know i can decide to buy a
couple of tara hash
on the open market almost like you do
energy credits i think we're going to
start seeing
that develop and that's going to create
a whole different asset class for
institutional investors because now you
can actually
invest in the bitcoin ecosystem
and you know do arbitrage on derivatives
that way which i think is going to be
really exciting
as more and more financial products
around that come out i think we're just
getting started
uh two more things i want to talk about
is uh when we talk about community
um most of us think of like the internet
right and that's twitter reddit
uh whatever else um but
you guys set a unique position because
you talk to the leadership of other
mining companies you talk to
you know what i'll call the whales or
other large players in the market
was there a difference between the
response from the executives at other
mining companies or like some of the
larger players in the market versus what
i'll just call like the internet
uh or did you hear kind of similar
feedback across the entire ecosystem
we got similar feedback across the
ecosystem our peers in the industry
looked at us and said you know
you guys aren't really playing by the
good of the community got it
yeah and and it's interesting to kind of
think through there because i think that
some of that is uh unknown right like
how do other miners feel about this and
and i guess another piece of the
analysis would be if all of a sudden you
know an institution can be hey we'll pay
you 10
more for that bitcoin how many of them
would have called you up and said hey
what's the criteria right like
uh fortunately i think that didn't
happen but
um you know we'll see how it plays out
second thing is
uh i think it's called the mining
council
uh the meeting with elon uh that michael
uh sailor put on just whatever you can
say about in terms of like
going into it kind of what was your
thought process of like
uh we're going to participate in this i
i think you guys are saying
um were you hoping to get out of it and
then like at the meeting i don't know
how much you can talk about like what
was actually discussed but just like
what did you get out of it right so
preface i wasn't actually on the call
okay our chairman merrick
uh okamoto was on the call but going
into it what we really wanted to do was
um really work with elon to help him
understand kind of what we're doing
uh you know he put out a tweet that
showed the carbon footprint
if it was all based on coal et cetera et
cetera of what was happening
with power consumption and so we really
wanted a address that with him let him
know kind of what we're doing and that
we are much greener than
um you know he put out to say and then
offer
the opportunity to collaborate and um
you know while i think he tweeted after
the meeting
uh a tweet that he was uh you know going
to collaborate with us
um yeah we'll have to see kind of what
he does i put out an
open invite to him yesterday on fox you
know and said hey we'd love to work with
you
on the technology right you know
renewable energy is
a technology that needs investment and
continued to drive the cost down
battery storage and utility scale
storage is a huge opportunity
that will benefit every single consumer
in north america and around the world
and the bitcoin mining industry could
fund a lot of that because it's helpful
to what we're doing
so i would love to collaborate with them
and any other technology providers in
that space
yeah um i forget who said it but
somebody said the use of the word
counsel
right was probably too uh not thought
out enough
right and like maybe association would
have given a different uh
inclination to it yeah and so let's hold
that constant of like forget
nomenclature for a second
what is your understanding of kind of
like what this mining association
council whatever
uh is gonna do moving forward is it kind
of like hey we're gonna meet you know
once a quarter
and we're gonna kind of just like help
each other best practices is it
more of uh we're going to all publish
the same report and
with data uh do you guys have elon's
cell phone number and you're gonna like
you know text
whenever something happens like like how
do you kind of just see us moving
forward
yeah uh i don't think we'll be texting
him um he'll tweet it you guys don't
yeah we'll copy him on a
tweet or two we might dm him but um
so you know the goal is uh really to
um provide a forum if you would for any
minor
to basically come and learn and also for
us all to educate
the marketplace not just the regulators
but also the general marketplace about
what we're doing
and so part of that is going to be
publishing commitments
here's what we intend to do over the
next year you know we've publicly said
that
our next deployment will be fully carbon
neutral and we'll
achieve a full carbon neutral over our
whole fleet by the end of next year
um and so we'll be held accountable to
that and you know even the small miners
uh to publish kind of you know here's
our current power footprint what the
sources we're using here's where we're
going to be
and then reporting on a regular basis
whether that's monthly or quarterly
that's to be seen
but the mission is really of education
and information sharing
um it's not uh you know i think somebody
tweeted you know oh this is opec
for mining it's not for one thing the
market share of the members is
fairly small still in the overall global
hash rate um
and it's open to anybody who wants to
join uh you know the good thing about
this industry is
every bitcoin is the same we don't
control the price the market controls
the price
um so there's no product differentiation
and there's no pricing differentiation
so it's really operational excellence
and it feels like uh a big
differentiation here is that
as far as i understood from what i've
read and people i've talked to there's
no like
hey we're going to come together and
make decisions right it's more so
we're going to come together and what
we're going to do is we're going to
agree from a publishing standpoint like
what con
what content what data should be shared
and it's more so
um almost like industry standards
more so than it was like let's all make
a decision
on an action that we're going to take
that has an effect on bitcoin the
blockchain
the mining process etc uh and so in some
way
if people can separate out like
hey let's talk about what internal data
we should share versus like
you know some of the other meetings that
have happened to bitcoin that haven't
turned out so uh
so well like 2017 yes uh
you guys are basically doing the former
right it's like we have all this data we
understand our energy mix we understand
um you know uh so much of what each
other's doing like we should all come
out and say it because it's gonna be
overall good for the industry
and so looking forward your publicly
traded company there's not too too much
you can say
but how do you see maybe like the mining
industry in north america evolving it
sounds like you think more hashrate's
going to come into north america
it's going to get greener and bitcoin
kind of continues to do its thing
and you guys are just better stewards of
mining and you know in public markets or
kind of how do you think about weak
issues yeah
i think yes we're going to see greater
growth in hash rate in north america not
necessarily because people are moving to
north america just the north american
miners are now very well capitalized
in both riot ourselves hive and others
um
have now valuations that allow us to
continue to deploy and grow
so um you'll see that grow as we get
bigger we have to be better at operating
our companies right the
environmental footprint that we create
is big and it's important that we
are good stewards of that um and we're
we have to be good stewards of our
shareholders capital and so as
fiduciaries you know public companies
have a
different responsibility than private
companies in that we have a broader
shareholder base
different interests and it's really
important for us that we provide
our shareholders with great exposure to
bitcoin and help develop the market but
also provide a really great return on
their investment
what's the thing that you're most
looking forward to moving forward or
there's like a specific milestone
or a certain development in not
necessarily even just the bitcoin mining
but just bitcoin in general that you're
like hey when this happens like that'll
be the next kind of
big inflection point in terms of
interest or anything like that yeah i s
when we start seeing d5 um
businesses launching on bitcoin when we
start seeing identity management
platforms
launching on bitcoin when we start
seeing um tokenized ownership of assets
launching on bitcoin that's when we're
starting to see the real mainstream you
know if you go back to the internet
analogy
you know late 90s you had to buy unix
servers and write custom
software to set up a website and it was
you know a multi-multi-million dollar
exercise
today you want to sell online you go set
up a shopify store it's super easy
um and so i think the bitcoin industry
is moving
there the faster it moves there um
the better and i think we're still in
that kind of uh honeymoon period
with a lot of these startups in the defy
world um where the concepts aren't
you know fully crystallized you know
there's a lot of really cool
um startups working today some really
cool things
we need to make them a little bit more
regulator friendly um
and then i think as we start seeing them
deployed on the bitcoin blockchain
that's when you'll start seeing
mainstream really
take over here um
do you have like a message to uh kind of
a bitcoin community just in terms of
like hey there's all this like nonsense
that happened
it feels like now you guys are saying
okay we're just gonna do what every
other miner's doing
is that like a fair categorization yeah
i think a better way to say it maybe is
hey we listened right we reacted
and we want to maintain a dialogue keep
talking to us you know
you know i understand that if when
you're not happy you want to complain
but you know personal attacks uh don't
help necessarily let's have a dialogue
you know
we have said um to a number of
influencers in the industry hey
listen you know we're more than happy to
have a group of people sit down and talk
with us and tell us what they think we
should be doing
you know we want that input um so make
it constructive
and you know i'm more than willing to
sit down with any groups
in the community and chat because i
think there's a lot we could do together
the people that you went and told that
to what was their response were they
generally receptive they were very glad
um you know i think what's interesting
is on the one hand you have the folks
who say marathon bent the knee
teens the game of thrones analogy um
which is great because we did
right we listened to the community and
we did react but at the same time we
really want to work with the community
to make bitcoin everything it can be
and there's just so much still to be
done in this industry and uh
you know i think there's a lot of people
who want to do it and if we all work
together i think we're going to get
there much faster
i couldn't agree more all right listen
uh a sign of intelligence
is changing your mind right like that
like that's not a bad
thing right it's actually a very good
thing and i think that uh the world
could probably benefit from people
doing that more often right listening to
folks getting more information changing
their mind
uh and uh i think you guys are serving
as a great example
um maybe we can all work together and
get elon to change his mind
who knows where his mind is today but uh
that would be the hope right
absolutely so absolutely uh where can we
send people to find you on the internet
or
find more about marathon yeah so i'm at
twitter f
g t h i e l um and otherwise
go to marathons twitter um and just you
know dm me on twitter more than happy to
chat with people that way
awesome well listen thank you so much
for doing this i hope you're enjoying
the bitcoin conference
and uh anyone's got questions just go
talk to great thank you very much
appreciate it of course